what is your definition of life what do
you understand this life
[Music]
entities of sufficiently high complexity
that are full of surprises
i don't know i don't have a free will so
that just came out of my mouth i'm not
sure that even makes sense there are
certain characteristics so complexity
seems to be a necessary property of life
and
i almost
want to say it has
ability to do something unexpected
it seems to me that life is the main
source of complexity on earth
yes and complexity is basically a bridge
head that order builds into chaos
by
modeling
by processing information in such a way
that you can perform reactions that
would not be possible for dump systems
and this means that you can harvest neck
entropy that dump systems cannot harvest
and this is what complexity is mostly
about
yeah in some sense the purpose of life
is to create complexity
yeah
increasing i mean there there's um
there seems to be some kind of universal
drive towards increasing pockets of
complexity
i don't know what that is that seems to
be like a fundamental
i don't know if it's a property of the
universe or it's just the consequence of
the way the universe works but there
seems to be this
small pockets of emerging complexity
that builds on top of each other and
starts
having like greater and greater
complexity by having like a hierarchy of
complexity little organisms building up
a little society that then operates
almost as an individual organism itself
and all of a sudden you have uh germany
and merkel but that's not obvious to me
everything that goes up has to come down
at some point
right so every if you see this um
big exponential curve number it's
usually the beginning of an s-curve
where something eventually reaches
saturation and the s-curve is the
beginning of some kind of bump that goes
down again
and
there is
just the thing that when you are in
sight of an evolution of life
you are on top of a puddle of negentropy
that is being sucked dry
by life and during uh that happening you
see an increase in complexity
because life forms are competing with
each other to get more and more and
finer and finer corner of that next
entropy extraction but that i feel like
that's a gradual beautiful process like
that's almost
you know follows a process akin to
evolution and the way it comes down
is not the same way came up
the way it comes down is usually harshly
and quickly
so usually there's some kind of
catastrophic event well the roman empire
took a long time
uh
but that's would that be would you
classify it as a decrease in complexity
though yes i think that this uh size of
the cities that could be fed has
decreased dramatically and you could see
that the quality of the art decreased
and it did so gradually and
maybe um
future generations when they look at the
history of the united states in the 21st
century will also talk about the gradual
decline not something that suddenly
happens
do you have a sense of where we are
are we on the exponential rise are we at
the peak
or are we the downslope
of the
the united states empire it's very hard
to say from a single human perspective
but
i it seems to me that we are probably um
at the peak
i think that's probably the definition
of like optimism and cynicism
so my nature of optimism is i think
we're on the rise
but
uh i think this is all a matter of
perspective and nobody knows but i do
think that erroring on the side of
optimism
like you need a sufficient number
you need a minimum number of optimists
in order to make that up thing actually
work
and so i tend to be on the side of the
optimists i think that we are basically
a species of grasshoppers that have
turned into locusts
and when you are in that locust mode you
see an amazing rise of population
numbers and of the
complexity of the interactions between
the individuals
but uh
it's ultimately the question is it
sustainable see i think we're a bunch of
lions and tigers that have become
domesticated cats
uh to use a different metaphor and i'm
not exactly sure
we're so destructive or just softer
and nicer and lazier but i think we have
monkeys and not the cats and if you look
at the monkeys they are very busy
are the ones that have a lot of sex
those monkeys not just the bonobos i
think that all the monkeys are basically
a discontent species that always needs
to meddle
well the gorillas seem to have a little
bit more of a structure but it's a
different different part of the tree
you